one of the single greatest moments with
Doctor Doom and the history of Marvel
Comics was during Secret Wars 2015.
check this out so Dr Doom basically
takes the power of the beyonders
basically becoming God and then he
basically assembles battle world where
he just kind of puts together a
hodgepodge of different universes
eventually Thanos steps up and Thanos
challenges Doctor Doom and like Thanos
is like if one's going to pretend to be
God or play God he shouldn't shy away
from it and so he starts like talking
all this mad trash and starts talking
about how if he had an Infinity Gauntlet
that like he could destroy Doctor Doom
and so Doom's like do you have an
Infinity Gauntlet with you and Thanos is
like no but I remain Thanos the gay
Tyrant and for you that will be enough
dude Doctor Doom punches a hole in this
guy's chest incinerates him down to his
skeleton and is like that would appear
to be untrue it was a ridiculously
amazing moment make sure you guys follow
for more